[Musique]
alors on est chez les parents de
pression et du coup tu sors pas toi jus
se sont tu sors pas ce soir non plus de
thunes mes couilles genre tout une pu
voir mon compte en banque doit on met
genre c'est ça qui va empêcher de sortir
tu vois si tu marches la gueule moi je
suis ok bah si c'était ça le problème on
gagne on commence pas ok c'est quoi le
problème la 1 m inquiète t'inquiète on
frère et c'est très bien de quoi je
parle c'est bien non c'est pas bien moi
je veux savoir c'est quoi eh ben on
papotait loup saguenay les comptes entre
super et bien sûr de vente assure
[ __ ] were bon y'a quoi c'est quoi
vas-y lui insupportable c'est
insupportable elle va entendre pour une
histoire elle veut comprendre pourquoi
tu veux pas sortir julien dix mois c'est
quoi c'est de la merde nul on passe
c'est toi la grosse merde
julien dis moi j'ai voulu pécho une meuf
hier soir je me suis foire est ok
c'était avant que tu rentres de tomber
de merde et donc
non pardon excusez moi j'ai vraiment pas
envie de ça je suis avec toutes mes
poches dans les zones non denses au
monde explique la sépulture acheteurs
s'est passé juste que ça fait deux
heures que tu joues avec mes couilles et
là dessus je tape alors parler d'homme
sage et et [ __ ] étroite qui se foutent
de ma gueule c'est général a tenté en
train de parler mes potes comme ça vire
d'attenté on aurait vu comme ça moi
c'est pas un mec c'est julien va baiser
tes potes maintenant casse toi s'il
tombe alors tu sais mon rang je vais
aller me baiser mes potes je vais bien
les baisers m'épater coutume à rester
tout seul avec tap toute petite querelle
serait du john mchugh articule déjà et
michael est très bien mais s'il te plaît
tranquille je me casse
souvent quand on a raison on se bat tu
sais quoi tu sais pas qui je suis tu
regretteras pas m'avoir rouler une pelle
chipie les braves petits culs
c'est toi qui parles mal à mon pote
alors devenu je te connais pas et de
deux cas très mauvaise haleine c'est un
nommé s'allume et salomé la good ou n'ai
pas de goût doux bien sûr que si l
écoute ou mais n'en avaient pas good way
to chat soit partout en deux mais
qu'elle ait pas que good ou lé be ok non
mais le truc possible ses confrères il
est mauvais marc était petit bichon il
n'y a pas de petit bichon avec son
téléphone la ses phrases tout péter qui
sort son gars qui pullulent quare au
bout du troisième mère indigne indigne
un bouffon quoi un vrai bouffon en
professionnel un pauvre type
une pauvre grosse mer mais c'est mon
staff on a compris julien tu as dis ça
oui je me suis foiré [ __ ] mais tenait
ça va je me suis excusé va s'en remettre
je pas non plus le plus grand des
connards c'était maladroit mais c'était
pas méchant
c'était maladroit hockey lève toi
lève toi ça vient les flèches tenus en
laisse toi fais moi confiance d'asie
hockey est un pro donc on imagine que on
est en terrasse tout est roi
ça fait une heure que que tu regardes à
ça et que tu as peu projet de la chope
et tu veux vraiment jouer là là
maintenant sur wii vas-y fais moi
confiance atteint les genres et dr
julian schieber skip oui ça fait une
heure que tu l'as remarqué qui a été
remarquée donc tu viens vers elle est
d'abord de la conversation
ok un salut tu viens boire un verre avec
moi salut et ouais je viens boire un
verre avec toi je te paie les filles non
mais rien julien c'est bien c'est bien
par contre tu peux pas lui parler comme
ça il faut que tu sois plus subtil jeu
subtil ouais tu comprends mots subtils
tête 220 soir est non mais sérieusement
c'est pas compliqué bordel ça fait une
heure théo barth avec tes potes et là tu
fais mec merde je fais le mec cool oui
genre vous regardez depuis une heure un
coup c'est toi un pouce et lé vos
regards se croisent alors tu viens vers
n3 commis hier juin tusson voilà donc tu
arrives vers elle les épaules voilà et
attaques dans l'est partout il faut pas
lui parler comme ça lui non m'attaque
pas mais c'est bien tu vois troisième
verte et détendue tu mates la fille la
fille tomates dont quelque part c'est
acté tu vois ce que je veux dire oh tu
es avec moi
genre c'est bon c'est dans la poche non
c'est pas bon
non c'est pas bon ok ça peut le devenir
d'accord et vous matez depuis tout à
l'heure donc à une attirance physique
maintenant faut aller lui parler
l'asie ok bon et julien les épaules
droites hop tu tiens droit bex et le
sourire c'est important c'est le premier
signe de confiance en soi thébaux g est
d'accord ouais nan ferme ta gueule et je
recommence ok alors un salut on se
regarde depuis tout à l'heure est ce que
c'est un très bon avec moi ah ça non
franchement en vrai c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal du tout mais je pense que tu
regarde mes potes si on veut que ça
marche mais c'est ça que je renvoie en
fait si je te veux toi pourquoi j'ai
regardé je m'en fout de vous en faites
et ben voilà on y vient comprend rien
regardes tu réfléchis je suis bien là
mois avec une copine
ok on se regarde mais je pense que ça va
être simple pour être avec moi non faut
que je la proba sont mes potes faut
qu'on sente toutes les trois que tu es
un mec bien en plus d'être beau tu as
juste à les considérer un peu juste à
regarder qu'elle passait à se propre et
d'un lâcher de temps et bien belle leçon
de liberté madame top et non mais à ça
la raison
tu viens vers nous tu nous regardes tu
nous considèrent et après tu regardes à
cela tu restes focus sur à ça ok
j'arrive je vous regarde je vous
considère vous de en tant qu'individu
féminin individuel je me tourne vers
votre ami salut je te regarde depuis
tout à l'heure et j'aimerais beaucoup
t'invite à boire un verre est ce que ça
te tente
ok bon le regard est top
oui j'ai senti c'est c'est bien mais par
contre la phrase d'accroché elle est
allée naze pourquoi parce que tu
faux-pas tutu ok bon julien on imagine
que tu es bien habillé d'accord ambiance
avec tes potes que je suis beau ferme ta
gueule
ferme ta gueule on imagine que tu es
bien habillé ambiance avec tes potes
d'accord que vous vous regardez depuis
une heure donc là tu fais le mec tu
arrives genou prend faustine et moi en
considération et life sorte de réplique
ouais mais ie réplique j'ai bien fait
juste avant alors que ouais c'était bien
non je sais pas tu arrives tu me dis ah
bah saluons c'était moi depuis tout à
l'heure on prendrait pas un verre
ensemble grave ça c'est bien tu vois
évidemment que c'est bien le gars qui
dit ça forcément moi je dis oui oui
normalement
je vous regarde je te regarde ça lui on
se regarde depuis ta leur faut qu'on
arrête de se mentir on se plaît est-ce
que ça tente de prendre avec moi ouais
avec plaisir tu rencontres avec nous
allez tu viens souvent ici non ouais
c'est un peu notre qg avec les filles je
crois que tu es déjà croisés si tu crois
où tu en es sûr je crois que je suis sur
ok
intel a bien sûr de toi je suis jamais
sûr de moi quand je parle de jolies
filles je sais pas ce qui se passe
attends tu l'a répété celle là ça se
voit oui oui mais franchement j'aime
bien mes bien-aimés c'est hyper bien
julien franchement bravo hockey à l'état
moi j'y vais passer une bonne soirée
cassez vous un jour tu sors pas avec nos
toits normalement cassez vous
non non et non et ses toiles on regarde
tout est tombé de mes pattes à moi et
oui aux élèves que tu ais je pense qu'un
truc voilà je vais prendre mes billets
est choqué c'est en australie pour
changer de vie vous êtes sérieux la
mauvaise et ça fait mieux que tu dises
ça t'a jamais prêter vie je t'écoute peu
a forcé bon ok bon moi je cherchais à
avoir ça non plus apparemment non mais
tu pense qu'en partant l'herbe est plus
verte ailleurs alors c'est faux ce
témoin julien tu voi le mec a vu un peu
le regard l'assurance il a toutes ses
chances donc du coup à salses et est
dragué direct lui il a toutes ses
chances un vieux blocs bareille les
surdiplômés je crois c'est ce qui m'a
dit d'accord mais s'il a des diplômes qu
est-ce qui branlent dernièrement m'étais
juste jaloux en fait maintenant puisque
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
me georges nommé genre mdr genre
mensonge watchmouse et j'estime qu'à ses
couilles à me chercher c'est ridicule
mais elle touche ici tu tombe en panne
est aussi déclare qui sert à vous ouais
après je te cache pas que c'est cool
dans les mois et que c'est de bien des
secours
problème en fait un monstre off on va
prendre plus de bière est ce que je pars
du picon dans la vienne stopper ça c'est
un euro en plus un euro 1
à la bonne heure on va faire ça on fait
ça c'est certain je suis là tout le
temps ça montre que j'ai ici avec les
nouveaux duc au nouveau nom c'est mon
deuxième jour deuxième jour un nom ça se
fait ce qu'on peut prendre quatre chocs
4 c'est mon deuxième jour et qu'on peut
les prendre pour toi si tu veux les
choix at on peut célébrer pour toi ok
réside en face à aller avec tout le
temps qu'on passe ici oui il a dit oui
ok ça ferait qu elle soit 14 quoi un
jambon reprendre 4 chaque jambe on va
prendre quatre points tu es ce que tu
vas voir ça avec le picon s'il te plaît
est ce que tu peux prendre ces deux et
ramenée déjà là bas moi je vous rejoins
touquet et j'avais prendre le reste
énorme manque deux t'appelles comment on
martin c'est génial ok away est tout
prêt relais grave kiffé habitations cet
aprem je suis hyper fier
franchement joli travail et vas-y donc à
ça ça vous savez c'est dans ce wagon
sans parvenir à faire désirer chine
souhaitait pas marrante
omar est assassin je veux tu le quittes
des airs regarde moi je suis pas comme
est par contre il est vraiment en train
de discuter que la gente féminine la
magnifique
oui enfin hier il veut parler jusqu'au
drame médias et s'est longtemps on a
tous le droit de se planter en fait
ouais enfin là on dirait une petite
sorte de bébé qui fait ses premiers pas
de choix une espèce de coquilles saint
jacques qui sort de sa coquille mais
sans la saint-jacques t'as vu en fait
c'est le père et que j'ai vu de loin
je verrai avant de te voir toi y ait un
côté un peu bonne et une plaque est très
intéressant ce genre de loin j'ai beau
ni plus les oncles alimente clyde il est
mince et ça s'est passé ça tu es tu a
saisi ma personne
il va finir par les voir c'est chaud
tout ouais là pour le coup c'est moi qui
en train de parler mais oui j'arrive
je crois qu'elle a l'air de
s'impatienter date à copier de quoi ta
copine non non non c'est la copine de ma
soeur donc à peu s'impatienter ya aucun
souci mais tente est venu celui ci non
je suis avec des posteurs hockey et bah
je te libères qui peut les rejoindre
des livres mais par contre selon moi
mais je vais les rejoindre ce nouveau
geste était pas fuir déjà si je passe en
coup de vent très rapide ok à tout
si tu travailles 200 pts comme une mère
mon frère on avait besoin de ces
postulats ouest attend quoi pourquoi
j'attends quoi tu me plaît je te revois
tes grands feux verts depuis des jours
encore pire cette aprem tombe
tu peux rien
normal quand tu fais ça je te prête ça
se voit un rythme au dehors
maintenant
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
je fume une clope venez empreinte jalma
vont être de plus deux bouquets roja
veut tirer les drames et pas du tout
change avec toi heureuse je t'aime non
mais moi je l'aimé
[Musique]